let's talk about why this is happening
so we have the story from the new york
post john stewart's
new show in apple tv is reportedly a
flop
well what happened
um jon stewart got woke
went broke look at bill maher bill maher
has been resisting and trying to pull
back but still pretty much playing the
establishment game but he's been calling
out wokeness and he's sort of maintained
an audience he's also never retired jon
stewart tried to make a comeback smack
talks white people and the problem with
white people gets panned for it and you
and i think i think most of you watching
used to watch jon stewart
i used to watch jon stewart now i see
him come back get well go broke let's
talk about this we were just talking
about libs of tick tock what is libs of
tick tock well the reality is it was an
aggregator it was a lens that was
aggregating the woke left the insane
things they say and do
and
presenting them in a feed
this was a powerful tool in the culture
war showing regular people what was
going on it resulted in outrage among
parents it resulted in potentially in
laws getting passed
now why would they try to target the
individual and try to destroy their
lives because wokeness is not popular
and it cannot win without brute force
trying to destroy when jon stewart tries
to get woke
it fails that's what they say get well
go broke right so they have to
like is this the funny thing if someone
is showing people what woke people are
like they have to shut it down they're
like no no no don't don't well
people because people are mocking it but
jon stewart's version of being woke was
meant to be a serious prominent
personality trying to get you to believe
in woke things and it's not working no i
remember he one of the first things he
came out against was calling harry
potter anti-semitic and then he went on
this whole sort of like retconning of
that where he actually went in and had
them change the video title on the
youtube card um in order because
originally that's right anti-semitism
right the goblins anti-semitism in harry
potter and then he changed it to just
anti-semitic tropes and he said no i
wasn't saying that harry potter was
anti-semitic i was just saying that
these tropes show up inside of harry
potter he's totally different so it's
like right well it's like he doesn't
know how to be woke because he's saying
the wizard himself
character yes
he called he's like i think he's a great
wizard i'd even say a grand wizard that
harry potter but i wasn't calling him
racist in any way
i think well there there's kind of been
a lot of jon stewart worship for some
bizarre reason over the past couple
years and i think that's because when
comparing him to john oliver or trevor
noah he's significantly less funny but
i've heard a lot of people say things
like when jon stewart was
the person making informational
left-wing comedy it was all fantastic
but
i gotta be honest he very much did the
clown nose on clown nose off thing that
we've sometimes complained about i
remember he was getting into an argument
with tucker carlson a couple years ago
and it was a very it was on crossfire
that's right it was a viral clip and
he's going on about all this
misinformation carlson is spreading and
tucker says well you've spread a lot of
misinformation on your show and his
response is it's a comedy show and i'm
sorry but when you're presenting
yourself as a comedy show that spreads
information to help keep people informed
you don't get to fall back on i was just
kidding when you get the facts wrong so
we did an episode about a year ago um
when luke was here and he and i got into
it over this over johnny stewart um if
you guys remember that you weren't here
that night but i think you three were oh
yeah and i was essentially making this
argument and luke was saying
but he had on ron paul he needed some of
these other things and i said look no he
was the leading edge of that he was
always the leading edge of the
weaponization of comedy and now it's
gone far beyond the seeds that he
initially said i i can agree you know i
think it's it's silly to look back and
and try to romanticize the the the era
of jon stewart but he praised project
veritas and this is a really good
example of at the bare minimum of how
things were different
he he mocked james o'keefe for wearing a
silly outfit not fit but that's fine you
know he was taking jabs at james for
dressing up the way he did and it was
actually like the normal clothes james
was wearing i forgot what he said but uh
what did he call it i don't know but uh
he basically was like journalists where
are you how are you getting scooped by
these guys which is you know he showed
the acorn reporting legitimately like
look at this and he didn't call james
o'keefe a liar he didn't say it was
deceptively edited he said wow look what
these guys accomplished at the very
least you have that now we're in the
media age where trump gets not a single
good day where everything james o'keefe
does is deceptively edited but it's
james but okay has jon stewart done that
lately
well no no john stewart has he has he
shared a project veritas he was retired
for several years it's almost comes back
now woke and broke he can't i'm not
literally broke figuratively broke yeah
my point is he's that leading edge he's
still that leading edge yeah i mean i i
just want to say i know you were going
to say something um but i just want to
drop this in there first before we we
potentially shift to something else it's
not to say that jon stewart's been wrong
about everything he's ever done or
everything he's ever said it's just that
like you said he was on the the leading
edge of all of this and whenever
somebody comes out and says something
even remotely sensible conservatives go
oh this guy gets it he's great he's our
guys need to stop doing that yeah it's
really frustrating
bill maher yeah that was gonna bring up
when stewart went on the jack dorsey was
it the tonight show with stephen colbert
is that he does a tonight show now um
and was talking about the coronavirus
and the wuhan laboratory of bat
coronaviruses across the street from the
market where they told us they found the
best coronavirus the hershey
chocolate the most
sensible aware normal human observation
i was like good jon stewart's
we all had within like one week or even
one day of hearing about uh the wuhan
lab we said oh there's a coronavirus
right across the street from a virus
factory i know it was it's hysterical
that's saying that it's possible that
the virus that originated right outside
of a virus factory it was insane to say
um maybe that came from the virus
factory and it was sensible to say that
it mutated in a bat and then someone ate
the soup
and that's how it all happened now when
jon stewart came out
semi out of retirement
disheveled and on colbert saying all of
these things we were like jon stewart's
back he's going to call out the media
for being dumb then what did he do got
up on his show and said the problem with
white people right and we're like oh
here we go the anti-semitism of harry
potter happened i've never heard him use
that language before i'll tell you what
here's what i think bill maher on his
show
he saw the tides because he was sitting
in it he saw people tweeting him he
probably talked to people and they were
like dude you're getting these things
wrong and he was like but those are
conservative things and they're like
listen you probably went
so bill maher i think is trying to play
both sides call out the world because
the vote goes too far but don't actually
entertain the fact the left is so far
gone that bill maher is conservative by
by today's like if they call me a
conservative bill morris to the right of
me on a bunch of things
but i think bill maher recognized that
and so he's like i'm going to call out
the woke a little bit jon stewart comes
back from his semi-retirement and he's
like okay what am i doing and they're
like here's what's happening if you want
to be a liberal guy and he went i'll
just say whatever i have to say to be
relevant
and so he was like okay what's that
people don't like white people let's do
a show about it
and then sure enough it turns out people
actually don't like any of that stuff
they don't like what jon stewart's
presenting on i think a really good
example
to understand the blue checks are wrong
and crazy is that when the mask mandate
was ended all these videos emerge of
people celebrating right there's a video
of a flight attendant singing and
dancing with a garbage bag because
everyone's
there they're throwing their masks in
and i'm like everybody hated that except
for blue check mark journalists who are
like you should sue delta if they make
you take your mask off did you if you go
in on the tweet about the the so the dc
metro has taken it off but then um
a buddy of mine who writes it pretty
regularly he says they don't really
enforce it anyway he said he was on it
once and um somebody wasn't wearing it
and then someone said something to like
the metro guy who was on there and said
hey this guy doesn't have his mask on
the metro guy was like uh i'm not a cop
man what do you want me to do i said
well neither are the flight attendants
right it also wasn't a law to begin with
but if you go and look at the tweet from
the dc metro and marina medvin had
posted this and she was screenshotting
all the quote tweets over the dc metro
we're sending the mask mandate and and
all they're saying by the way is it's
optional right it's optional to wear
which by the way if you go to asia china
south korea japan mask wearing if you're
sick is pretty normal it's pretty
normalized it's always been around uh
certainly since they dealt with sars
navy and flu and some of the other
things but with with this one people
were freaking out and then g prime had a
really good tweet this morning about it
where he said just imagine if you will
you're mid-flight in a flying coffin
you could have you could enter the voice
comes over the intercom they start
taking the masks off that guy and now
you're spreaded by the plague and the
worst thing of all the guys smiling the
guy who uh tweeted what did he tweet
that i was on the planet through masks
and this is manga air or something
yes and then a journalist reached out
from the new york times
was like can you tell me about your
experiences like well it was satire but
something only a a journalist would have
believed right i saw that i hope she
wins that g-prime image of the plane i
didn't know who it was or what it was
and i thought oh this is some
far some whacked-out journalist that
hates the the mandates were lifted i was
like wow this is trash propaganda and
then i saw the name yeah and my entire
perception of the image changed so at
some point maybe we should put satire
above things that are satire starting to
sound like snopes i thought if his name
wasn't on that i would have thought it
was some some more like somebody that
was all that hated that lifting the
requirements
look look look i got to say you need to
be training you need to be putting on
speed these people will chase you five
or six at a time you might have to run
away from them screaming if you go
anywhere near a whole foods if you go
anywhere near a supermarket airports
they congregate in these spaces ian i'm
telling you they will swarm and if two
or three of them scurry away from you
right when they see you unmasked in the
aisle
keep up your situational awareness
maintain your guard and your psychic
defenses at all times because they could
be returning with numbers
okay
frightening people no i gotta be honest
hold on the g prime i thought the g
prime comic was historic
where he tries to create these like very
intentionally banal left-wing comics his
whole idea is he's trying to like get
into the head of a new york times
cartoonist and they're really funny he
does a very good job problem i'm having
with satire and this is why i dislike
stephen colbert for so long with his old
show satire show is that there's so much
lying going on right now in the universe
that i need honesty and i can't the
people that i if the people i trust
start saying things that aren't true
just for an effect i gotta disengage i
can't listen to that stuff or or respect
it interesting thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you